ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants au que se passe-t-il
nounours mettront mon petit doigt vient
de me dire qu'il faut que je descende
mettre de l'ordre j'ai mes deux petits
amis tu crois oui on a besoin de moi en
rond ou léchage hop hop hop hop
on soir nico
omep après noël tuân le pyjama de ton
frère
séverin
unicolore la prix sont bas et il va
chercher ton pyjama mon pyjama tiendront
s'annonce tendu non plus je mets
ma première
allons mon pyjama geffroy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien beau de 10 mois toulouse son
pyjama patronne est bon
mais petit pape rhône limite ma chemise
de nuit oui nicolas tu peux mettre la
chemise de ta soeur c'est toujours une
jeune fille à jamais
quintana lui est à me rende mon pyjama
salon à ses filles
son terrible elle vous prend toutes vos
affaires c'était coquine des chips de
pyjamas des vilaines cantonade laden ne
pas habiter avec ta soeur toit ni non ce
n'est pas du jab à bois
tiens
ta chemise de nuit pas prodel
soit raisonnable c'est le pyjama de
collants alors ne pas attendre une arme
en haut je n'aime pas les enfants qui se
disputent puisque c'est comme ça je m'en
vais et je ne sais pas si je reviendrai
demain
tfh panne ou bien la voilà les pyjamas
du gardon d'abord il est pas beau et
jean vais pas m a tant mieux parce que
moi je les aime bien ça suffit cette
résidence est chamayou il n'est pas une
[Musique]
excuse moi tu sais la fille
endormie vous vite et ne vous disputez
plus jamais non plus si ce tram et à
demain adam
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
alors nounours ton petit doigt ne s'est
pas trompé il ne se trompe jamais mon
petit doigt pas trop et j'ai mis de
l'ordre
on y va oui en route lol lol gollum beau
la vie est belle vous ne trouvez prendre
très belle nounours bonne nuit les
enfants fait de gros
lots
oh
[Musique]
où